[Music]  me and Kylie and Khloe are planning like  one of those kids photo shoots just like  a silly shoot that we can have all the  girls cuz stormy and Chicago have so  many pictures together so we can't wait  for true to join the crew well the day  has come  the littlest Kardashian Jenner's  apparently just had the cutest cousins  photo shoot  Khloe teased the pics on Twitter  announcing her little one true head post  with Kim's baby girl Chicago and Kylie's  daughters stormy but we'll have to wait  for the pics Chloe didn't share any  first looks now the three little girls  are gonna grow up together  hey mama hi baby true lookin like a  little lady Chloe also opened up to her  followers about adjusting to motherhood  admitting while it's beautiful it isn't  always glamorous quote sometimes I don't  know what day it is or I don't get a  shower lol what's the most unexpected  gift in all of this gosh is having a  family yeah  you